everybody in the world all the boys and
girls it's a little segment I like to
call why I'd hate to be Asian Oh what is
going on YouTube
now it has been a while since I've seen
or done one of these videos for those of
you who haven't seen or heard about this
video is about a kid from Indiana
University who talks about why it sucks
to be Asian you must be out your
[ __ ] you have not learned from
Alexander Walters mistakes and now I
want to go ahead and do this [ __ ] but
let's just hear what you have to say
most in look alive I don't want to look
like you're gonna that's to doing bad
you know why the little thing buddy
most Asians look a lot huh you blonde
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't look like
anybody else but me [ __ ] you know what
let me tell you something you better
pray to Buddha that all of us don't look
a lot because when you get your ass beat
how are you what identify food through
the seven ninja stars at Joe dig this
right be a check you got your ass beat
by five different animal styles I got
crane fader monkey snake you know what
you lucky I emigrated an early age
because I don't know karate but I'll
show us [ __ ] no car rented by Stiles get
drill pipe and let dental [ __ ] ranch you
could have found a bigger one too
come on make it your oh god this thing
whatever the [ __ ] what is this
there's number two it was amazing man
guesses are probably using Asians
I'll find you an attractive kill me huh
was it you don't find Asian women
attract you kill you [ __ ] kill yourself
so let me get this straight in your
country ass [ __ ] your mind if you were
an Asian man you are only allowed to
find Asian women attractive huh dumbass
interracial couples are everywhere and
in case you haven't noticed uh we humpin
everybody this baby right here don't you
look away this is my half white
interracial Korean baby cousin you tell
me that baby ain't cute yeah by the way
why are you so worried about finding an
Asian woman attract him they would have
to be attracted to you first looking
like the ugly cousin of a Jonas Brother
get the [ __ ] on out of here with Joe
extra-medium sure well you get that
shirt I have a copy in the [ __ ] yo sure
so tight that should look like a short
sleeve wet suit [ __ ] Miley Cyrus
called she wants her shirt bad reason
for free sweatshop haisa don't work goes
into a push-up squish shop suck no [ __ ]
oh my god out of the many years you live
on earth you've deduced by yourself that
sweatshops suck
good job douche to be honest with you at
this point I'm trying to figure out your
logic so you're telling me you would
hate to be Asian because if you're Asian
you would have to work at a sweatshop do
you think when an Asian baby pops out
the blow of the first day goes with a
sweatshop the kid you carnival [ __ ] do
you think my dad was like daddy leave a
sweatshop in Korea to go to you in some
America bye daddy
to work on American sweatshop do the
world a favor take a hammer and smash
your face off you imagine how you would
look you're a high agent call Gingka
right go to 30 I'm Chi guys don't you
close top that the best you got up the
whole time you were at work you decided
to document this on a video that's the
best thing you came up with [ __ ]
there's Asians RJ guys if they smoke are
they wait for it
double check on haha [ __ ] smash you
take off sucka don't be mad because any
people see a widescreen that's
b-baby and whose eyes are you talking
about your eyes aren't even that big the
only thing big on your face is that
big-ass brown edge of your Sahel is with
your brown line looking like a crow
magnum your cavemen looking for talking
about how somebody else's when you look
like you missing a chromosome you Barney
Rubble looking [ __ ] Matt Matt I [ __ ] it
man
I'm told I'm not bigger than that I was
in algebra I don't even know if all I'll
do but help with mr. Scott
my senior year tell me graduate do you
work in algebra your senior year of high
school who the [ __ ] let you into a
university algebra was taught in the
seventh grade you got into University I
go there somebody had a suck a lot of
big events on you thugs that at least
graduated high school knowing geometry
dude at that point gang should be
looking at you like damn he does a
stupid I personally don't know what
you're trying to get it I don't know how
saying the Asian people are good at math
is a negative trait something you don't
suck at math because you're white you
suck at math because you're stupid
understand why you so worried about man
you barely have a grasp of the English
language with that Forrest Gump son of
yours [ __ ] you can't even pronounce
sushi I totally hate sushi sushi sushi
sushi sushi I can't even say how awful
it is the education system has failed
you miserably you don't make me mad not
only are you racist you are trying to be
funny I understand if you were going to
PO stupid [ __ ] why would you post it on
a public forum the Alexander walls call
you up and break ass so should I like
post this video and they got yeah I'd
like to do it right now yet cuz I Ching
chongs love again like I said before I
don't usually hate people outright but I
[ __ ] hate your guts personally I'm
not a computational human being but I
can wish the worst upon you I want a
blonde Asian man with carpal tunnel to
give you acupuncture so he will [ __ ]
your nerves up
I don't wonder you accidentally rub
tiger balm on your eyes [ __ ] you know
what type of my man why people got icy
hot tiger balm is hot and burning no
hate I hope you get Alexander Wallace
one day and you'll have to compete up in
half Navy by us so in the future my
babies can meet you
babies and seduce the [ __ ] out that's
why hope you haven't done just so my son
who show your daughter is caked on
linglong look people in all honesty is
it unacceptable
yes it is but be aware people just
because he's an individual that put up a
video doesn't mean that he is unique
then a lot more people like him you
would think that by now in today's
society we have progressed beyond
something like this but the fact of the
matter is we have not oh and by the way
all my Asian brothers and sisters that
are threatening his life and sending him
racist comments don't do that because it
doesn't make you any better just do what
I'm gonna do cinema Tamagotchi says [ __ ]
yourself right all right yeah money in
my pocket yeah looking like The
Forgotten vampire Twilight the [ __ ] out
of here